all right on to part f what's it asking
us use the fact that sine x is greater
than or equal to 2 on pi times x in this
particular domain to show that this
particular inequality is true so you can
see we're relating bn to this unusual
looking integral here how do we do this
well i'm going to start with this
particular inequality here and they
don't tell you that you need to prove
this but it's actually very
straightforward to see what it's talking
about and why
sine x we know what that looks like if i
just draw myself a very quick and dirty
sketch over here
good old sine x like so
when you think about 2 on pi x this is a
straight line goes to the origin and
it's got a gradient of 2 on pi now in
the particular domain that we're
thinking about
x equals pi on 2 is a specific point for
this particular line because when you
substitute in
pi on 2 here you get 2 over pi times pi
over 2 so you get 1 right what does that
mean what's the significance of that
well at pi on 2 let's use this the scale
is awful but that's okay
at pi on 2
you're going to be going through exactly
1 which is in fact the top of that graph
there right there's 1. so when you
compare sine x with the straight line 2
on pi
x here's that straight line 2 on pi x
and you can see sure enough sine x is
greater than or equal to that straight
line i mean here's the rest of it you
know it goes over here and over here but
in this little domain you know sine is
always higher okay not that you needed
to prove that but we're going to use
that as our kind of launch pad for
proving this inequality okay
the other piece of information that's
helpful to know is that when you compare
this particular integral i mentioned
this strange integral over here right
we're comparing it to b n and you can
see there's some similarities and
differences right the similarities are
you've got this term i use purple this
term out the front here in the integrand
the x squared that's in regular old bn
and then you also have this power of n
right so what's usually there for b n
is you would normally expect that
there's a cos
two or rather a cos squared x in there
right because when you raise that to the
power of n that'll give you the cos to
the 2n x that we've been working with
for so long throughout this question but
instead we don't see that we see this so
clearly whatever has been replaced by it
like this thing uh this thing here the
cost squared is equal whereas this thing
here must be less than or equal to so
that's what we're going to try and show
as i mentioned before let's just begin
with this result here this inequality
and what i'm going to start off by doing
is you can see i've i want to get
towards a cos squared i've got a sine so
the most obvious direct way to do that
as we've already done a couple of times
in these earlier parts is via the
pythagorean identity i'm going to square
both sides now you have to be careful
with doing that because with an equation
you're fine doing pretty much any
operation to the left and right hand
sides simultaneously but with
inequalities you have to be cautious
right if i'm going to square the right
hand side which gives me 2 on pi x all
squared
this would not be true i would violate
this inequality if the left and the
right hand sides if i had like a
negative positive relationship going on
that was going to ruin this so just as a
quick example right i could say that 1
is greater than or equal to negative 3
right but if you square both sides you'd
get 1 on the left hand side and 9 on the
right hand side and you're in trouble
because that is no longer true right
the reason i can say it in this case is
because i don't have the particular
quality that this inequality over here
has that breaks my ability to square
both sides namely this negative and this
positive right both of the things i'm
dealing with in the given domain are
positive so i should invoke that i
should state it as my reason for why
this is a legitimate operation okay so
i'm going to say i can do this since
sine x is non-negative and 2 on pi
x is also non-negative for this
particular domain from naught
to pi on 2 i almost instinctively said 2
pi
okay so fantastic we've got that stated
so how do i take this and then transform
it to something which i can relate to to
this question up here okay
well what i'm going to do is i've got a
sine squared so i want to get towards a
cos squared right and that's going to
sort of get me to here which will get me
up into this result so if i want to get
cos squared i've got my sine squared
already i'm going to use 1 minus sine
squared so let's do this one step at a
time just not to miss things right to
get a 1 minus sine squared i need to
multiply both sides by minus 1 like so
whoops don't write that i'll write
multiply that by -1 as well but
multiplying both sides of an inequality
by minus 1 is going to reverse the
direction of the inequality so i've
switched that around just be careful for
it
and then at the same time i actually
don't want minus sign squared i want 1
minus sine squared so i might as well
add 1 to both sides while i'm at it of
course the adding 1 doesn't change
anything about the direction of the
inequality
so that looks good that allows me to
replace this left hand side with cos
squared
and i've got on the right hand side and
this should look familiar right when you
square it out that 2 squared becomes a 4
there's a pi squared on the denominator
and then there's an x squared right so
this is looking really promising because
if you go back to the original question
this is the term
over here that you can see inside the
brackets being raised to the power of m
so again why don't i just keep on going
through that right i'm going to raise
both sides to the power of n
that will give me
cos to the 2n
x is less than or equal to one minus
four on pi squared x squared and by the
way you know we've also got qualities
about n that make this a legitimate
thing to say to power n um i'm not doing
any like we square roots cube roots that
kind of thing
and then from here in order to get to
the result i'm required to prove i
really just need to perform this
integration right and just to be a
little bit cautious with this because
just like with things like you know
squaring both sides or multiplying by a
negative those kinds of things
you actually have to state why you're
allowed to do the things that you're
doing and it doesn't violate the
direction of the inequality right so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
apply the integral from naught to pi on
2
of not just what's on the left hand side
the right hand side but x squared times
what's on the left hand side and the
right hand side like so so there's the
first bit
and i'm going to claim that doing this
to both sides preserves the direction of
well it's not that i'm doing the right
left hand side there just grab this and
be lazy that
like so and that's with respect to x i
claim that this is true and the reason i
can do this is because much like i did
here right over this situation looking
at this particular domain and looking at
the operation from 0 to pi on 2 what i'm
going to be multiplying by like this is
a signed area right integrals tell you
signed area but thankfully x squared is
above the axis so therefore it's not
going to muck about with my positive
negative thing here which would normally
be an issue so i'm going to say this is
true
since
obviously daisy since
x squared is greater than or equal to
zero i don't even need to attach a
domain to that because that's true for
all real values of x
and if you have a look what have i done
on the left hand side i have b n and on
the right hand side i have everything
that i needed so i can say that's all
true as required
okay so you're going to see these last
few points here like if you have a look
at the working ah part f wasn't so
arduous that's why it was just one mark
and we're going to continue this train
towards the end of the question so here
comes part g